hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and in this video I want to give you an
orderflow imbalance strategy all right
because you know imbalances are one of
sort of the the building blocks
cornerstones of trading with orderflow
now before I begin you know if you've
been enjoying my videos be sure to hit
the Subscribe button and smash that like
button as well as the notification
button so you get notified whenever I
post a new video all right so let's jump
into the orderflow imbalance strategy
now for those of you just really quick
that aren't that don't understand what
an imbalance in the order flow is is you
know what you look at on the footprint
chart is the volume traded on the bid
and the volume traded on the offer in a
bar and sometimes you have what's called
an imbalance where in the two-way
auction between the bid volume that
traded and the offer volume you know
it's above a certain ratio I use 4:1 um
some people use you know 3 to one which
is 300% other people use a higher number
um you know 10 to one but it it
really sort of the industry standard you
know the one that I've I've used for
over a decade is is 4 to one I think
that's that's good enough um once you
start getting out to lower um imbalance
thresholds you know like 3 to one you
which is 300% um you're going to get a
lot more imbalances you know you want to
be at a level where you're comfortable
with uh the amount of imbalances that
you see in a bar and you know keep in
mind you know depending on the market
that you're trading um you know some
markets seem to distribute volume a lot
better than others so if if you're in a
market like say um you know mini da ym
or mini NASDAQ um that has thin volumes
at times you you know you you can get a
lot more
imbalances than you know you really
would in a normal market now what I got
up here is crude oil this is a 30-
second chart and you know whether you're
using a a 30 second chart a one minute
chart you know a range based chart a
tick based chart volume based chart uh
the same rules for this strategy apply
to any of those chart types all right so
you can see here on the footprint right
there's the bar and you have volume
trade on the bid volume trade on the
offer your normal volume in the two-way
auction that is colored uh black but
sometimes you're going to have red on
the buy side and blue on the offer side
okay so if it's red it's telling you
there's a salent a balance 24 against 5
if it is blue it's a IM balance 0
against 10 um you know 20 against 89 10
against 52 2 against 39 now you could
see in here I just pull up my settings
really quick this is the orderflows
trader software that I developed I first
first edition came out about 10 years
ago um we're already on our our version
seven you see in here imbalance trigger
in percent now you know in the sort of
the basic way that Traders bfol Traders
use imbalances is they look for stacked
imbalances where you have you know three
imbalances stacked neatly on top of each
other if it's three buy imbalances like
you have here 1 two three that is a
stacked buying imbalance if you have uh
let's see if I can find here here's a
stack cell IM balance where you have 1 2
3 four imbalances stacked neatly on top
of each other that is a stacked buying
and a stacked selling imbalance
example okay and you know over the years
as we developed the
software one of the things that I
noticed
is you know what happens after the
imbalan forms because it's one thing to
have a stacked imbalance okay because
you know that could be an example of
just a big order being executed in the
market is sort of the most common
example uh sometimes you get you know
stacked imbalances when a stop gets
triggered um sometimes you you know you
can have a stacked in Balance because
you know a lot of Traders are coming in
at the same time with the same uh
expectations of the market
now most software will allow you to
highlight those uh stacked imbalances
okay and the order flows Trader is no
different so here let me just put it on
here stacked in balance and you know
most software will just highlight the
area in the bar with the Stacked
inbalance you can see here right it's
green color green color over these three
prices right here okay and for stack
cell balance it's going to color it red
here what I found is
you know not just me but you know other
Traders as well will attest to this is
stacked imbalances are often a nice sign
of support in the market or resistance
right support if it
is stack buying IM balance or resistance
if it's a stack sell on a balance
so one thing that you can do to help
with that that I like to do is I draw
out the Zone I draw I I create a zone
for it and I draw it until tested okay
meaning that if if you have a stacked
inbalance and the next bar trades into
it it's not going to draw out a Zone but
if the next bar is above it right right
here it's going to start keeping that
zone being drawn out until it tests it
again okay and you see this zone is
being drawn out way to over here now
again not all the time is it going to
stop right at the level but what I found
is you know a lot of times within the
first um two or three bars you can come
in and test it so here right this is
your stacked buying imbalance then in
the next bar we open up right in that
imbalance and then trade higher just
over here on the stack sell a balance we
have the stack excuse me stack sell a
balance Market starts trading down a
little bit and then it comes right back
into that
imbalance and then start selling off
right so that's sort of a an easy way to
use stacked imbalances you know watching
how the market reacts when it comes back
to that level right if it starts coming
back to that level and then moves away
chances are you have some Market
generated support or resistance right
resistance if it's a stack sell in
Balance support if a stack buying in
balance that you can trade around right
you can just sit there and wait you know
I know some Traders they what they do is
they see this setup up here they just
throw an offer somewhere in that stacked
imbalance with the stop right on the
other side they get stopped out fine
okay just wait for the next one now when
you're using these zones like this what
I found is sort of the longer the zone
is the less important it is when it
comes back down to it when it comes back
down to it you know after in this case
this is uh
819 doesn't come back down till 843 so
good you know 20 some minutes later by
that time you know this to me the
Stacked imbalance the the support that
it's generating it's already worn off
because too much time has
elapsed okay so that's a simple one
right stack buying and stack selling and
balances now I like to take things a
step further because you know it's one
thing to have a stack selling balance
like right here okay but wouldn't it be
nice to have a sign based off of the
imbalances a lot earlier right because
the high was just made up here at 835
the stacko balance doesn't come in until
8:42 okay so what I've found out you
know over the years just by watching a
footprint chart for such such a long
time is you know there's going to be
bars that
have multiple buying and balances or
multiple selling
imbalances that aren't necessarily
stacked on top of each other the way you
know the stack selling imbalance or
stack buying IM balance is so neatly
done right so here in this case you got
one imbalance up here another one and
another one so you got three imbalances
that are kind of spread out in the bar
now does that mean that it is less
important because it's not stacked on
each other the way it is here
no right it it to me it carries just as
much importance okay so you know what
we've done in the orderflows trader
software is we made it easy for you to
see okay so you go under volume
imbalances where is it right down
here and you enable multiple imbalances
now you could either draw it out in the
bar itself or you could draw it out as a
Zone the way you did with stacked in
balances but first I'll show it to you
just in the bar itself right it will put
a box around the bar right if it's if
it's bullish it'll be right here right
it'll be this green box if it's bearish
it'll be this sort of this Orange Box
you can change the
colors um doesn't really matter and
it'll put like it'll color in the bottom
cell of the bar or the top cell if it's
a green bar bottom cell if it's a if
it's a red bar right and you know that's
just a visual thing you don't have have
to color in the bottom of the bar at the
top of a bar if you don't like it right
but uh you know what I that's just
something to highlight to you as a
Trader hey you know what you have this
taking place in the market right because
that's really what you know you want to
your software to do is to highlight
these important pieces of information
coming in so I know we just made a high
right here right because this green line
is the high of the day we start coming
off right wouldn't I it be better to be
getting short somewhere up here around
the you know 60 area 7760 area then you
know 20 uh down here at 7720 you know
that's good 40 points that you're
missing out on simply because you're not
looking at bars that have multiple
imbalances right because you're just
waiting for stacked imbalances right so
to to say that you know just because
it's not a stacked imbalance it doesn't
matter well it is important right
because you have that aggressive selling
it's just not neat in the sense the way
the Stacked selling a balances so you
know stacked buying a balances the stack
selling stack selling imbalances are
nice but bars that exhibit multiple
imbalances you know spread out in the
bar are just as important probably more
important because people aren't looking
for them right everyone is looking for
stack selling a balances or stack buying
imbalances they're not necessarily
looking at Market where there's
imbalances that are spread out now you
could even take it one step further okay
let show you guys a
little a little thing here with the
order trador software and as far as I
know I'm the only software that has this
you know because we developed the
software for you know I've been a Trader
whoops um you know for a long time
before I even developed this software so
I know what I want to look for that's
why I put these things in here is
drawing out the zone until tested cuz I
want to show you guys something this is
important to
understand okay so you'll notice right
if it trades back in now since it's a
multiple imbalances if the bar just
trades right into it in the next bar um
you're not going to have a
Zone Zone drawn out here okay here let
me just pull up the the settings here
I'll show you guys oops is you change it
from fixed until tested right which I
just showed you but uh show you again uh
I was someone was shouting in the
background uh multiple imbalances draw
zone until tested okay now remember
right the this it's going to color the
bottom of a red down candle and the
reason why you do that actually is
because we want to see the market trade
below that level okay however right just
as on the green candle it's at the top
of the bar there there's times when you
have the green candle with the zone at
the top but it doesn't get violated in
the next
bar right you see there was one here one
here right Market sold off came all the
way back this is actually a bit of a
reversal
signal so if it doesn't trade up past
that in the next
bar it's a nice little short opportunity
you I I say that and then this next one
right here this one would have stopped
you but you could got short here right
and look at some of these here um you
know again that one stopped you out
where is it here right here's a nice one
right this is a short one right if
you're sorry a long trade we're trading
above the low of the bar with the
multiple selling IM balances right you
got a nice little move up there here's a
bullish multiple buying and balances
right but we're trading below it you go
down and again you know it's it's about
finding opportunities
where you know I'm not going to go so
far as to say these are trap traders in
here because you got aggressive buyers
buying it up but then the aggressive
sellers you can see coming in in the
next
bar but what is taking place right
what's happening in the market is yeah
these guys are caught on the wrong side
of the
market right now again you know I hate
using the term trap Traders because you
see 11 you know six you know this bar is
only 173
contracts that's it's not like it's
10,000 buyers here they're all trapped
and they're all scrambling to get out
right you can see what the volume is
even these buyers here you know 30 20
you know that's 50 you know it's about
100 on the on the trade on the offer
side okay so again you know you hear the
term trap Traders and you think oh
there's so many people trapped in
they're scrambling to get out well they
can trade 100 in the next bar or two you
know whoever's trapped in there could
get out very easily
but I guess the point I'm trying to make
is you know when you see the market
doing the opposite of what you're
expecting it to do right multiple buying
and bounces multiple aggressive buyers
here you're expecting this Market to go
higher and it's not doing that in fact
it's doing the opposite it's telling you
there's something
bigger taking place in the market okay
so you know you got to pay attention to
it whether you take the trade or not you
got to respect that because you have the
multiple aggressive buyers coming in
here but it's not enough to move this
Market higher instead the selling
pressure
is stronger than the buying pressure all
right over time and you see the market
sell
off you know for a decent opportunity
all right guys so that is you know
actually it's probably a couple or three
orderflow imbalance strategies for you
there to take apart all right so thanks
and again you know if you haven't
already be sure to subscribe to the
channel and hit the notification bell
all right everyone take care bye-bye